[Music]
Demi Lovato is in stable condition
tonight after reportedly overdosing on
heroin the trouble figure had to be
rushed to the hospital yeah Nancy this
is a heartbreaking story because Demi
has been so open about her struggles
with sobriety and just last month she
admitted that she had fallen off the
wagon but now there is this alarming
development conscience I wasn't ready to
get sober sneaking it in bathrooms
sinking it throughout the night
nobody knew downward spiral a lot of
demons
she's been an addict more than sober for
most of her adult life these are the
quotes coming in from a source as news
of Debbie's overdose spread early this
afternoon I was either craving drugs or
on drugs and I remember thinking oh my
god I might be overdosing right now
[Music]
last month demi confessed she had fallen
off the wagon after being cleaned for
six years she released her song sober
her last photo this Instagram she posted
Monday afternoon showing off her newly
blonde hair
Demi was on a road to Lake suicide she'd
have liked bags of pills and an eight
ball of coke apparently in late May Demi
had a falling out with her sober coach
our source adds she's depressed has
anxiety and is always late she pushed
people away also struggle with past
behaviors kind of and cravings creeping
in we're told Emmys relapse happened
sometime between April and May when she
was on break from her tour there's a
drive that I have to stay sober because
I know that my life depends on it
now reps for Demi have not responded to
our request for a comment we will have
so much more tomorrow including the
latest on her recovery yeah work with
her on a TV special she could not have
been lovely no shouldn't nicest girl I
wish
[Music]
[Applause]